[Applause]
thanks for being here i'm glad you
stayed less for me to do
yeah no no i'm staying out of the way
but happy to see you i was in the park
happy to see you looking down and away i
was in the park as well
well i didn't hear the joke so i but i
think you should have told it i liked it
i enjoyed it you told it on the show
okay now i feel awkward he is the host
[Laughter]
here just take it just take it no ah
you've won it just take it
like the uh you're growing a beard uh
growing the operative word i suppose how
long have you been working on this
oh i like to think since you know
forever
sort of uh you know emotionally but it's
really only been
coming out for a few weeks that's a
couple of weeks i can relate to this
gary can you grow
a manly beard in a short period of time
i'm not prepared to discuss this
you've got sideburns i noticed uh hey
lately i just uh i
call me choppers i just let them go a
little bit i like them they've made me
read
i just frightened gary uh no i i can't
uh i i don't really ever get a chance to
grow the the beard but
we should do it together and we could
race to a designated
you know stopping point that'd be great
if we held hands and grew a beard
together yeah
that sounds terrific uh on that you guys
want to be alone yeah
yeah uh you know the
since i last saw you the oc ended and i
got to think this is uh
yeah it's over uh i know they told you
they said
they said i didn't know and no one told
me wow it really happens that way
did uh is that at all gotta be
tough for me yeah heartbreak and you
were with this fake family for a number
of years i know
fake breakfast and fake advice yeah and
uh
yeah no now it's weird i like call my
real parents and talk to them and it's
not exactly the same
right it's not a snappy it's no it's not
as it's not lit
as well the screens are kind of but uh
it's okay
i mean i still talk to most of the
people so right
um it's it's it's good i think it's a
natural progression i feel good about it
last time you were on the show you were
talking about how your character and the
ryan character
were spent so much time together and
were so palsy
that part of you hoped these series
would end with the two of you running
off together
yeah to be as one was there they didn't
go for it they didn't go for it um
i wish we oh no i mean i think
spiritually and emotionally
they are together i mean they i may have
gotten married to summer i believe
but um i think the law you didn't even
watch the last episode did you
i did it was a montage it all happened
very fast a lot went down in the last
two minutes
and hard to keep uh dibs on all of it
yeah but i think everyone ended up
fairly happy
except uh misha she died yeah her
character's gone
uh now what are you doing now you got
some free time are you learning any
what do you do what are you doing do you
cook are you i don't like cooking
i would love to uh i'm trying to be
productive i would love to cook i think
i'm gonna get a bike and
ride it um but these are big dreams my
friends big dreams one day at a time
one day i'll buy a bike i'm going to um
i don't cook because
i eat very fast so it always seems
like more trouble than it's worth that
was the most audible sipping i've ever
heard on television
i'm an actor so i play to the you know
what i mean it's like movie trained
what are you worried about gary well you
know i think you're fantastically
behavioral oriented which is what actors
are i just wonder if i could get you
some soup
some food oh yeah well you drink to the
back of the room you're doing things
because it's hot out i um brought the
weather i'm hearing
yeah no
and then it's cold it's that good
weekend weather yeah
promises good things for all of us do
you um
it's interesting this show will not air
this show
tonight's show will not air this will be
at the museum of broadcasting if you
want to see
it it's interesting that sometimes it's
uh good weather
and sometimes it's called global warming
well that's what everyone that's the
thing now every time like this day is
great
and it's december everyone says yeah
it's good i'm telling you i should go
the man is uncomfortable he's between
two lunatics and he wants to talk about
it
let me go and you continue he would love
it if you would stay
i feel comfortable i'm on your side 100
there's a movie to discuss i believe
uh
[Applause]
meg ryan this is a big movie it's a big
move huge yeah
yeah global warming huge um
it's really good to see it in the
theaters preferably
okay or in a pirated dvd or
well we've got it up at 114th street
well maybe i'll come and i'll do the
signing with you
i did um i worked with uh
meg and uh uh harley burley a movie
called yeah sure
yeah wow
so this is uh behind the actor's studio
now i suppose
i mean i didn't come on conan to talk
about it no that's okay listen let's
plug that too all right now what is the
movie oh please i don't feel sorry
if this is the worst he's he said he
said it's uh in the land of women
and uh with with meg ryan and uh it's by
warner brothers and it's um
it's in theaters now yeah so check that
out in the land of women
i really think meg is like one of the
funniest uh
uh women uh around she's she's
practically underrated for her comedy
i agree and true uh but in this one
she's more dramatic in a good way i
believe she's underrated it as a
dramatic yeah
she's a rated period she's underrated as
a human being she is
she's thankful
[Applause]
if it's okay with gary we'll take a
little commercial break now
[Applause]
adam brody thank you very much for being
here in this
very strange experiment